foreign
this is Aaron
he's not available right now
uh-huh
yes sure I'll give you a message when he
gets up gets back
Michael had chicken pot pie for lunch
actually let me rephrase that Michael
had an entire
chicken pot pie for lunch and let me be
more specific Michael ate an entire
family-sized chicken pot pie for lunch
and then he promptly fell asleep so
we're all trying to be very quiet
supposed to not wake him up before 5 PM
which
actually should be in about
10 minutes
what do you need from me
normally I don't condone leaving early
but I have an appointment with the horse
doctor how that horse became a doctor I
don't know
[Laughter]
no I'm kidding he's just a regular
doctor who shoots your horse in the head
when its leg is broken
hmm
like clockwork
oh
[Music]
okay geography joke oh
oh wow okay all right let's all go home
come on see you all to Molly
see you later Michael
all righty let's get started what is she
into I know Pam pretty well I know the
things that she likes and just as
important I know the things that she
hates so one of the things that she
likes is pranks
and the things that she hates
frisbee based competitions are you
kidding me
I started the main Frisbee Golf Club at
Cornell
where I went to college I lived to froth
lead off with that
well she loves hunting
she also loves those ads for Six Flags
with the old guy also
[Music]
do you speak Pig Latin
hello this is Dwight Schrute
hello hello this is Dwight
hello hello yes we do have that hold on
one second Jim what are you doing and
how many would you like uh hang that up
right now absolutely I can get that out
to you immediately this man is an
imposter do not do business with him
this is not quite true Dwight left his
cell phone on his desk so naturally I
paired it to my headset
okay fine I'll just let it go to
voicemail
hello this is Dwight hey is this Dwight
yes it is my goodness you sound sexy oh
thank you I've been working out whoa
whoa whoa pam pam you are not talking to
Dwight right now you are talking to Jim
Dwight no
Pam I'm over here
confused disconnect that right now you
give me your earpiece can't do that I'm
sanitary
ah okay you know what fine I will
reprogram my phone to go to my office
phone
Mr Dwight oh and I forwarded his desk
phone to mine
oh hello Mother good news I've married
tell father
hope this helps
Jim
nice what are you doing
be scared
it works
oh no
Pamela mading dong
listen you're cute
there's no getting around it
so I don't know if you like country
music but I was thinking maybe one of
these days we could drive out to a field
crank up some tunes smoke a few back and
noodles
maybe even toss a disc around
but wait
i h
I'll hit you back
wow
that was
wow
okay night
oh you know what
sorry I forgot to tell you I intercepted
a transmission earlier and it seems that
the CIA is going to need Dwight down in
their headquarters at Langley for
training and an ice cream social with
the other agents
we should get him a bus ticket
to make his trophies here I don't know
it costs 75 dollars
an helicopter
you have been compromised abort Mission
destroy phone
Michael since it is your 15th
anniversary at the company I thought it
might be appropriate to begin the
festivities with a 15-minute Round of
Applause I like it followed by a
15-minute moment of silence I don't know
is it classy enough Jim enough with the
classy okay I just feel like after 15
years of this company Bravo by the way
that we should celebrate with a very
classy event a night to remember I think
you're right this party has to have all
the excitement drama and Intrigue of my
time here and of course
classy and classy yeah Michael
you're just agreeing with him because
he's wearing a tux don't you see what
he's doing here last week Dwight sent
out a memo about the dress code so this
is me showing him that I'm taking it
very seriously
oh here's one a string quartet playing
classical music
you know that's good but it's not classy
I I need something
classy like the opening of a car
dealership that's it or Mr Peanut yes Mr
Peanut is not classy yes he is a regular
peanut he just happens to have a cane a
monocle and a top hat that's what makes
him classy okay how about this an ice
sculpture shaped like you covered in
chocolate covered strawberries oh Dwight
you're trying too hard and that's just
not classy see the thing about classy is
it's a state of mind well I'm sorry I
just don't know what class he is then
okay let's just try this one on for size
and I apologize because it's right off
the top of my head
then ice sculpture of you completely
surrounded by a variety of chocolate
covered fruits strawberries that's
inspired I said that
[Music]
not classy not classy at all day class a
French
classic
you ready you kidding
I was born ready
[Music]
um
I don't know how to tell you this but
we have a little bit of a problem
oh no what
the minister just told me that it's
tradition for the bestest Mensch to be
older than the groom
oh come on I've never heard of such if I
haven't heard of it obviously
but I'm out because I'm significantly
younger than you not significant as a
big word I think you're well okay either
way either way Dwight
I can't be there for you
I'm sorry
Jim I just
really wish there was something I could
do
I can't believe you came
that's what you said
[Laughter]
best prank ever